DEMOCRATS CAN‘T DO SOMETHING ABOUT CRIME JOINING ME NOW IS THE
CAN‘T DO SOMETHING ABOUT CRIME JOINING ME NOW IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
CRIME JOINING ME NOW IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL ACTION NETWORK AND HOST OF MSNBC‘S
ACTION NETWORK AND HOST OF MSNBC‘S POLITICS AND POLITICS NATION,
AND HOST OF MSNBC‘S POLITICS AND POLITICS NATION, REVEREND AL SHARPTON.
POLITICS AND POLITICS NATION, REVEREND AL SHARPTON. SO, REV YOU‘VE BEEN AT THE
REVEREND AL SHARPTON. SO, REV YOU‘VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF EFFORTS TO
SO, REV YOU‘VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
FOREFRONT OF EFFORTS TO ADDRESS POVERTY CRIME, POLICE
ADDRESS POVERTY CRIME, POLICE BRUTALITY.
POVERTY CRIME, POLICE BRUTALITY. FOR DECADES. I MEAN, ALL OF
BRUTALITY. FOR DECADES. I MEAN, ALL OF THESE ISSUES
FOR DECADES. I MEAN, ALL OF THESE ISSUES IN A LOT OF WAYS ARE
THESE ISSUES IN A LOT OF WAYS ARE INTERCONNECTED
IN A LOT OF WAYS ARE INTERCONNECTED AND YOU FROM YOUR VANTAGE
INTERCONNECTED AND YOU FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT. HOW HAS
AND YOU FROM YOUR VANTAGE POINT. HOW HAS JOE BIDEN CHANGED ON THE
POINT. HOW HAS JOE BIDEN CHANGED ON THE ISSUE OF CRIME FROM?
JOE BIDEN CHANGED ON THE ISSUE OF CRIME FROM? FROM 1991 UP TO THE
ISSUE OF CRIME FROM? FROM 1991 UP TO THE PRESENT?
FROM 1991 UP TO THE PRESENT? WELL, I
PRESENT? WELL, I WATCH CAREFULLY.
WELL, I WATCH CAREFULLY. HERE‘S AN ATTORNEY GENERAL
WATCH CAREFULLY. HERE‘S AN ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND STATEMENT TODAY
HERE‘S AN ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND STATEMENT TODAY BECAUSE I
GARLAND STATEMENT TODAY BECAUSE I PROTESTED THE 94 CRIME BILL,
BECAUSE I PROTESTED THE 94 CRIME BILL, ALMOST 34 YEARS AGO.
PROTESTED THE 94 CRIME BILL, ALMOST 34 YEARS AGO. WHEN AS YOU CORRECTLY SAID,
ALMOST 34 YEARS AGO. WHEN AS YOU CORRECTLY SAID, MOST OF THE
WHEN AS YOU CORRECTLY SAID, MOST OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS AND
MOST OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS AND MANY CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS AND MANY CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS SUPPORTED,
MANY CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS SUPPORTED, A LOT OF THE REACTION
SUPPORTED, A LOT OF THE REACTION WAS TO THE HIGH CRIME AT THE
A LOT OF THE REACTION WAS TO THE HIGH CRIME AT THE TIME,
WAS TO THE HIGH CRIME AT THE TIME, WHICH ALL OF US WANT TO DEAL
TIME, WHICH ALL OF US WANT TO DEAL WITH BUT WE DID NOT
WHICH ALL OF US WANT TO DEAL WITH BUT WE DID NOT FEEL THAT THREE STRIKES AND
WITH BUT WE DID NOT FEEL THAT THREE STRIKES AND YOU‘RE OUT AND
FEEL THAT THREE STRIKES AND YOU‘RE OUT AND GIVING
YOU‘RE OUT AND GIVING DISPARITY,
GIVING DISPARITY, DISPROPORTIONATE SENTENCES TO
DISPARITY, DISPROPORTIONATE SENTENCES TO PEOPLE WITH CRACK COCAINE
DISPROPORTIONATE SENTENCES TO PEOPLE WITH CRACK COCAINE AS OPPOSED TO LOSE COCAINE
PEOPLE WITH CRACK COCAINE AS OPPOSED TO LOSE COCAINE WAS, WAS THE ANSWER AND IT WAS
AS OPPOSED TO LOSE COCAINE WAS, WAS THE ANSWER AND IT WAS GOING TO LEAD TO WHAT HE DID
WAS, WAS THE ANSWER AND IT WAS GOING TO LEAD TO WHAT HE DID LEAD TO
GOING TO LEAD TO WHAT HE DID LEAD TO MASS INCARCERATION
LEAD TO MASS INCARCERATION TODAY, THEY DID NOT GO
MASS INCARCERATION TODAY, THEY DID NOT GO AT THE END OF THE
TODAY, THEY DID NOT GO AT THE END OF THE CRIME LINE AS MUCH AS THEY DID
AT THE END OF THE CRIME LINE AS MUCH AS THEY DID THE BEGINNING, WHICH IS WHAT
CRIME LINE AS MUCH AS THEY DID THE BEGINNING, WHICH IS WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE EARLY
THE BEGINNING, WHICH IS WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE EARLY 90S, THEY TALKED ABOUT
WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE EARLY 90S, THEY TALKED ABOUT GUNS, THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW TO
90S, THEY TALKED ABOUT GUNS, THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW TO GUNS GET INTO OUR COMMUNITY,
GUNS, THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW TO GUNS GET INTO OUR COMMUNITY, THEY TALKED ABOUT DEALING WITH
GUNS GET INTO OUR COMMUNITY, THEY TALKED ABOUT DEALING WITH MANUFACTURING AND GO.
THEY TALKED ABOUT DEALING WITH MANUFACTURING AND GO. LAWS. AND I THINK THAT, THAT
MANUFACTURING AND GO. LAWS. AND I THINK THAT, THAT IS A
LAWS. AND I THINK THAT, THAT IS A WISER APPROACH,
IS A WISER APPROACH, BUT I WOULD HASTEN TO ADD
WISER APPROACH, BUT I WOULD HASTEN TO ADD JELENA THAT THEY NEED TO
BUT I WOULD HASTEN TO ADD JELENA THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE
JELENA THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE SURE AS THEY PUT THESE THINGS
MAKE SURE AS THEY PUT THESE THINGS INTO PLACE
AS THEY PUT THESE THINGS INTO PLACE THAT THEY ALSO
INTO PLACE THAT THEY ALSO PASS
THAT THEY ALSO PASS LAWS
PASS LAWS LIKE THE GEORGE FREUD
LAWS LIKE THE GEORGE FREUD CRIMINAL POLICING ACT SO THAT
LIKE THE GEORGE FREUD CRIMINAL POLICING ACT SO THAT WE DO NOT CREATE AN
CRIMINAL POLICING ACT SO THAT WE DO NOT CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE
WE DO NOT CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE WHERE POLICE ARE
ATMOSPHERE WHERE POLICE ARE THEREFORE LET LOOSE
WHERE POLICE ARE THEREFORE LET LOOSE WITH NO FEDERAL LAWS THAT.
THEREFORE LET LOOSE WITH NO FEDERAL LAWS THAT. TELL THEM HOW FAR THEY CAN
WITH NO FEDERAL LAWS THAT. TELL THEM HOW FAR THEY CAN GO.
TELL THEM HOW FAR THEY CAN GO. WHILE THEY
GO. WHILE THEY CONFISCATE THE GUNS OF GO
WHILE THEY CONFISCATE THE GUNS OF GO AFTER THE GUN
CONFISCATE THE GUNS OF GO AFTER THE GUN MANUFACTURER.
AFTER THE GUN MANUFACTURER. THEY MUST READ THIS WHOLE
MANUFACTURER. THEY MUST READ THIS WHOLE QUESTION OF GUN VIOLENCE.
THEY MUST READ THIS WHOLE QUESTION OF GUN VIOLENCE. WITH
QUESTION OF GUN VIOLENCE. WITH LEGISLATION.
WITH LEGISLATION. BECAUSE JUST LIKE, WE WERE
LEGISLATION. BECAUSE JUST LIKE, WE WERE IN THE ERA OF NO ONE COULD
BECAUSE JUST LIKE, WE WERE IN THE ERA OF NO ONE COULD HAVE LAID OUT BETTER THAN YOU
IN THE ERA OF NO ONE COULD HAVE LAID OUT BETTER THAN YOU DID TONIGHT. WE WERE
HAVE LAID OUT BETTER THAN YOU DID TONIGHT. WE WERE THERE OF HIGH CRIME. WE WERE
DID TONIGHT. WE WERE THERE OF HIGH CRIME. WE WERE IN THE ERA OF RODNEY KING
THERE OF HIGH CRIME. WE WERE IN THE ERA OF RODNEY KING IN THIS TIME, WE‘RE IN THE
IN THE ERA OF RODNEY KING IN THIS TIME, WE‘RE IN THE ERA OF RISING GUN
IN THIS TIME, WE‘RE IN THE ERA OF RISING GUN VIOLENCE
ERA OF RISING GUN VIOLENCE TICK UP AND GUN VIOLENCE
VIOLENCE TICK UP AND GUN VIOLENCE AND GEORGE. FLOYD, AND
TICK UP AND GUN VIOLENCE AND GEORGE. FLOYD, AND WE CAN‘T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE
AND GEORGE. FLOYD, AND WE CAN‘T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE WHERE WE HAVE A
WE CAN‘T MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE WHERE WE HAVE A UH, NAN IMBALANCE AND HOW WE
WHERE WE HAVE A UH, NAN IMBALANCE AND HOW WE REACT TO ONE AND NOT
UH, NAN IMBALANCE AND HOW WE REACT TO ONE AND NOT BALANCE IT WITH
REACT TO ONE AND NOT BALANCE IT WITH WITH THE OTHER.
BALANCE IT WITH WITH THE OTHER. RIGHT. SO DO YOU THINK THAT
WITH THE OTHER. RIGHT. SO DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
RIGHT. SO DO YOU THINK THAT THIS ADMINISTRATION PARTICULARLY
THIS ADMINISTRATION PARTICULARLY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION PARTICULARLY WITH THE ADDITION OF SENATOR KAMALA
WITH THE ADDITION OF SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS WHO COMES FROM A
ADDITION OF SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS WHO COMES FROM A BACKGROUND AS A
HARRIS WHO COMES FROM A BACKGROUND AS A PROSECUTOR
BACKGROUND AS A PROSECUTOR BUT ALSO HAS
PROSECUTOR BUT ALSO HAS ACTUALLY A REALLY DIFFERENT
BUT ALSO HAS ACTUALLY A REALLY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE,
ACTUALLY A REALLY DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE, EVEN AS A PROSECUTOR
PERSPECTIVE, EVEN AS A PROSECUTOR ON, WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
EVEN AS A PROSECUTOR ON, WHAT ARE SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS TO
ON, WHAT ARE SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS TO CRIME?
SOLUTIONS TO CRIME? AND IN SOME WAYS, I FEEL LIKE
CRIME? AND IN SOME WAYS, I FEEL LIKE THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
AND IN SOME WAYS, I FEEL LIKE THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS ADJUSTED THE
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS ADJUSTED THE PERSPECTIVE. IT‘S THINKING
ADJUSTED THE PERSPECTIVE. IT‘S THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THE CAUSES
PERSPECTIVE. IT‘S THINKING ABOUT WHAT ARE THE CAUSES OF CRIME,
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE CAUSES OF CRIME, RIGHT? GUNS POVERTY,
OF CRIME, RIGHT? GUNS POVERTY, LACK OF EDUCATION.
RIGHT? GUNS POVERTY, LACK OF EDUCATION. RUSSIAN LACK OF HOUSING, LIKE
LACK OF EDUCATION. RUSSIAN LACK OF HOUSING, LIKE A RESOURCES AS
RUSSIAN LACK OF HOUSING, LIKE A RESOURCES AS OPPOSED TO SIMPLY FOCUSING ON
A RESOURCES AS OPPOSED TO SIMPLY FOCUSING ON THE
OPPOSED TO SIMPLY FOCUSING ON THE PUNISHMENT FOR CRIMES AS
THE PUNISHMENT FOR CRIMES AS A DETERRENT TO CRIME. IS THAT
PUNISHMENT FOR CRIMES AS A DETERRENT TO CRIME. IS THAT IS THAT A GOOD SUMMATION?
A DETERRENT TO CRIME. IS THAT IS THAT A GOOD SUMMATION? SUMMATION OF SORT OF THE
IS THAT A GOOD SUMMATION? SUMMATION OF SORT OF THE SHIFT, YOU SEE?
SUMMATION OF SORT OF THE SHIFT, YOU SEE? AND EVEN HOW THIS
SHIFT, YOU SEE? AND EVEN HOW THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND EVEN HOW THIS ADMINISTRATION TALKS ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS
ADMINISTRATION TALKS ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS VERSUS HOW, YOU KNOW, SENATOR
TALKS ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS VERSUS HOW, YOU KNOW, SENATOR JOE BIDEN USED TO TALK ABOUT
VERSUS HOW, YOU KNOW, SENATOR JOE BIDEN USED TO TALK ABOUT IT, WHICH FRANKLY
JOE BIDEN USED TO TALK ABOUT IT, WHICH FRANKLY FEELS
IT, WHICH FRANKLY FEELS OUTDATED.
FEELS OUTDATED. I THINK THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
OUTDATED. I THINK THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT
I THINK THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS BRINGS A
TO SAY THAT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS BRINGS A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS BRINGS A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE, WHICH IS GOOD
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE, WHICH IS GOOD AND, AND GIVE SOME
WHICH IS GOOD AND, AND GIVE SOME BALANCING. AND I ALSO THINK
AND, AND GIVE SOME BALANCING. AND I ALSO THINK THAT JOE BIDEN
BALANCING. AND I ALSO THINK THAT JOE BIDEN SELF HAS GROWN AND
THAT JOE BIDEN SELF HAS GROWN AND HAS OPENLY SAID THAT THE
SELF HAS GROWN AND HAS OPENLY SAID THAT THE CRIME BILL OF 94 WAS
HAS OPENLY SAID THAT THE CRIME BILL OF 94 WAS NOT
CRIME BILL OF 94 WAS NOT DONE RIGHT? AND THAT
NOT DONE RIGHT? AND THAT HE COULD SEE WHERE
DONE RIGHT? AND THAT HE COULD SEE WHERE NOW THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE
HE COULD SEE WHERE NOW THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE THINGS DIFFERENTLY. HE CAME TO
NOW THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE THINGS DIFFERENTLY. HE CAME TO NASHVILLE NETWORK,
THINGS DIFFERENTLY. HE CAME TO NASHVILLE NETWORK, MARTIN LUTHER KING BREAKFAST
NASHVILLE NETWORK, MARTIN LUTHER KING BREAKFAST BREAKFAST IN
MARTIN LUTHER KING BREAKFAST BREAKFAST IN TEEN, 2019. AND OPENLY
BREAKFAST IN TEEN, 2019. AND OPENLY SAID, WHERE HE WAS WRONG.
TEEN, 2019. AND OPENLY SAID, WHERE HE WAS WRONG. AND
SAID, WHERE HE WAS WRONG. AND ASPECTS OF THE CRIME BILL. SO
AND ASPECTS OF THE CRIME BILL. SO I THINK SOME OF THAT
ASPECTS OF THE CRIME BILL. SO I THINK SOME OF THAT HE SEEN THE RESULTS
I THINK SOME OF THAT HE SEEN THE RESULTS OF WHAT WAS DONE,
HE SEEN THE RESULTS OF WHAT WAS DONE, I THINK THE CONGRESSIONAL
OF WHAT WAS DONE, I THINK THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
I THINK THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS THAT WAS SUPPORTED IN
BLACK CAUCUS THAT WAS SUPPORTED IN 94 IS NOT SUPPORTIVE NOW.
THAT WAS SUPPORTED IN 94 IS NOT SUPPORTIVE NOW. WITHOUT THESE RESTRAINTS, LIKE
94 IS NOT SUPPORTIVE NOW. WITHOUT THESE RESTRAINTS, LIKE A GEORGE FLOYD BILL.
WITHOUT THESE RESTRAINTS, LIKE A GEORGE FLOYD BILL. SO I THINK THE CLIMATE IS
A GEORGE FLOYD BILL. SO I THINK THE CLIMATE IS DIFFERENT.
SO I THINK THE CLIMATE IS DIFFERENT. THE REALITY THOUGH.
DIFFERENT. THE REALITY THOUGH. AND THE THING THAT BOTHERS US
THE REALITY THOUGH. AND THE THING THAT BOTHERS US THE MOST IS THAT
AND THE THING THAT BOTHERS US THE MOST IS THAT BLACKS LIVED IN THE
THE MOST IS THAT BLACKS LIVED IN THE WORST EBOLA.
BLACKS LIVED IN THE WORST EBOLA. WORLD‘S, WE ARE AFRAID OF THE
WORST EBOLA. WORLD‘S, WE ARE AFRAID OF THE COPS AND THE RHOMBUS
WORLD‘S, WE ARE AFRAID OF THE COPS AND THE RHOMBUS AND WE NEED
COPS AND THE RHOMBUS AND WE NEED THERE ARE LAWS THAT WILL SAVE
AND WE NEED THERE ARE LAWS THAT WILL SAVE US FROM BOTH.
THERE ARE LAWS THAT WILL SAVE US FROM BOTH. IN TERMS OF THE
US FROM BOTH. IN TERMS OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU‘VE HAD
IN TERMS OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU‘VE HAD RECENTLY WITH THE WHITE HOUSE,
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU‘VE HAD RECENTLY WITH THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT ARE IF YOU CAN
RECENTLY WITH THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT ARE IF YOU CAN SHARE SOME OF THE
WHAT ARE IF YOU CAN SHARE SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS YOU‘VE HAD ABOUT
SHARE SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS YOU‘VE HAD ABOUT THE ISSUE OF CRIME, I KNOW
CONVERSATIONS YOU‘VE HAD ABOUT THE ISSUE OF CRIME, I KNOW THAT YOU‘VE HAD A LOT OF
THE ISSUE OF CRIME, I KNOW THAT YOU‘VE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
THAT YOU‘VE HAD A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE POLICING BILL THAT IS BEING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE POLICING BILL THAT IS BEING CONSIDERED IN THE SENATE.
POLICING BILL THAT IS BEING CONSIDERED IN THE SENATE. AND YOU‘VE MET RECENTLY WITH
CONSIDERED IN THE SENATE. AND YOU‘VE MET RECENTLY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT HAS
AND YOU‘VE MET RECENTLY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT HAS THE ISSUE OF,
THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT HAS THE ISSUE OF, YOU KNOW THE RISING CRIME
THE ISSUE OF, YOU KNOW THE RISING CRIME THAT‘S HAPPENING AROUND THE
YOU KNOW THE RISING CRIME THAT‘S HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW HAS THAT
THAT‘S HAPPENING AROUND THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW HAS THAT COME UP IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS.
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW HAS THAT COME UP IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS. DISCUSSIONS. I‘VE
COME UP IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS. DISCUSSIONS. I‘VE TALKED TO CEDRIC RICHMOND,
DISCUSSIONS. I‘VE TALKED TO CEDRIC RICHMOND, WHITE HOUSE ABOUT IT.
TALKED TO CEDRIC RICHMOND, WHITE HOUSE ABOUT IT. WHO HAS HIS EAR TO THE GROUND?
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT IT. WHO HAS HIS EAR TO THE GROUND? AND I THINK HE HAS A
WHO HAS HIS EAR TO THE GROUND? AND I THINK HE HAS A SENSITIVITY
AND I THINK HE HAS A SENSITIVITY THAT IS GOOD
SENSITIVITY THAT IS GOOD TO BE THERE ON THE WEST WING,
THAT IS GOOD TO BE THERE ON THE WEST WING, AND I THINK THAT
TO BE THERE ON THE WEST WING, AND I THINK THAT HE IS VERY SENSITIVE TO THE
AND I THINK THAT HE IS VERY SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO DEAL
HE IS VERY SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS WITH BALANCE
FACT THAT WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THIS WITH BALANCE AND THAT THEY‘RE GOING TO HAVE
WITH THIS WITH BALANCE AND THAT THEY‘RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO COMMUNITY
AND THAT THEY‘RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO COMMUNITY POLICING THEIR NEED, THE
TO DO COMMUNITY POLICING THEIR NEED, THE VALIDATORS OF THOSE OF US THAT
POLICING THEIR NEED, THE VALIDATORS OF THOSE OF US THAT ARE ON THE GROUND
VALIDATORS OF THOSE OF US THAT ARE ON THE GROUND THAT WORKS IN THESE
ARE ON THE GROUND THAT WORKS IN THESE COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY.
THAT WORKS IN THESE COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY. BECAUSE ALL OF THIS IS BUILT
COMMUNITIES EVERY DAY. BECAUSE ALL OF THIS IS BUILT ON AS ANY COMMUNITY
BECAUSE ALL OF THIS IS BUILT ON AS ANY COMMUNITY ON TRUST. AND I THINK HE
ON AS ANY COMMUNITY ON TRUST. AND I THINK HE OOPS, I‘M COMFORTABLE WITH
ON TRUST. AND I THINK HE OOPS, I‘M COMFORTABLE WITH CEDRIC
OOPS, I‘M COMFORTABLE WITH CEDRIC RICHMOND BEING RIGHT IN THE
CEDRIC RICHMOND BEING RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THESE
RICHMOND BEING RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THESE CONVERSATIONS, BUT AGAIN,
MIDDLE OF THESE CONVERSATIONS, BUT AGAIN, THE PROOF IS GOING TO BE AN
CONVERSATIONS, BUT AGAIN, THE PROOF IS GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT. WE NEED BOTH
THE PROOF IS GOING TO BE AN IMPORTANT. WE NEED BOTH LEGISLATIONS DONE, WE NEED
IMPORTANT. WE NEED BOTH LEGISLATIONS DONE, WE NEED WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO DO
LEGISLATIONS DONE, WE NEED WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO DO WITH POLICING AND WE
WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO DO WITH POLICING AND WE NEED WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO
WITH POLICING AND WE NEED WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO DO ABOUT
NEED WHATEVER THEY‘RE GOING TO DO ABOUT FELICI TO BE DONE AT THE SAME
DO ABOUT FELICI TO BE DONE AT THE SAME TIME, YOU CAN‘T DO ONE
FELICI TO BE DONE AT THE SAME TIME, YOU CAN‘T DO ONE AND THEN THE OTHER AND THEN
TIME, YOU CAN‘T DO ONE AND THEN THE OTHER AND THEN YOU
AND THEN THE OTHER AND THEN YOU IN THAT GAP MAY HAVE SOME
YOU IN THAT GAP MAY HAVE SOME INCIDENTS THAT WOULD
IN THAT GAP MAY HAVE SOME INCIDENTS THAT WOULD ALL TURN IT ALL THE WAY
INCIDENTS THAT WOULD ALL TURN IT ALL THE WAY AROUND.
ALL TURN IT ALL THE WAY AROUND. RIGHT? IT FEELS TO ME LIKE IF
AROUND. RIGHT? IT FEELS TO ME LIKE IF YOU DON‘T HAVE A
RIGHT? IT FEELS TO ME LIKE IF YOU DON‘T HAVE A BALANCED APPROACH TO THIS,
YOU DON‘T HAVE A BALANCED APPROACH TO THIS, YOU WOULD END UP LIKE WE
BALANCED APPROACH TO THIS, YOU WOULD END UP LIKE WE DID IN THE 90S WITH YOU, THROW
YOU WOULD END UP LIKE WE DID IN THE 90S WITH YOU, THROW MONEY AT THE PROBLEM,
DID IN THE 90S WITH YOU, THROW MONEY AT THE PROBLEM, YOU JUST SEND A WHOLE BUNCH OF
MONEY AT THE PROBLEM, YOU JUST SEND A WHOLE BUNCH OF POLICE OFFICERS AND THAT
YOU JUST SEND A WHOLE BUNCH OF POLICE OFFICERS AND THAT ACTUALLY DOESN‘T DO MUCH
POLICE OFFICERS AND THAT ACTUALLY DOESN‘T DO MUCH TOO LONG. I MEAN, THE CRIME
ACTUALLY DOESN‘T DO MUCH TOO LONG. I MEAN, THE CRIME RATE DID FALL BUT I WOULD
TOO LONG. I MEAN, THE CRIME RATE DID FALL BUT I WOULD ARGUE ACTUALLY THAT,
RATE DID FALL BUT I WOULD ARGUE ACTUALLY THAT, IT‘S NOT BECAUSE OF THE
ARGUE ACTUALLY THAT, IT‘S NOT BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED PRESENCE OF POLICE.
IT‘S NOT BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED PRESENCE OF POLICE. THAT WAS DETERRING CRIME,
INCREASED PRESENCE OF POLICE. THAT WAS DETERRING CRIME, OTHER CONDITIONS
THAT WAS DETERRING CRIME, OTHER CONDITIONS CHANGED
OTHER CONDITIONS CHANGED DO YOU THINK THAT THE
CHANGED DO YOU THINK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS
DO YOU THINK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THAT? THEY
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THAT? THEY CAN‘T JUST ADD MORE POLICE
THAT? THEY CAN‘T JUST ADD MORE POLICE OFFICERS
CAN‘T JUST ADD MORE POLICE OFFICERS THROUGH THE, TO THE STREETS,
OFFICERS THROUGH THE, TO THE STREETS, TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM, THAT
THROUGH THE, TO THE STREETS, TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM, THAT THEY NEED THAT
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM, THAT THEY NEED THAT NUANCED AND BALANCED APPROACH,
THEY NEED THAT NUANCED AND BALANCED APPROACH, THAT YOU‘RE TALKING ABOUT,
NUANCED AND BALANCED APPROACH, THAT YOU‘RE TALKING ABOUT, NO, I THINK THAT I THINK THEY
THAT YOU‘RE TALKING ABOUT, NO, I THINK THAT I THINK THEY DO IN MY
NO, I THINK THAT I THINK THEY DO IN MY CONVERSATIONS,
DO IN MY CONVERSATIONS, THEY,
CONVERSATIONS, THEY, THEY CERTAINLY THE VICE
THEY, THEY CERTAINLY THE VICE PRESIDENT. UNDERSTAND IT AND
THEY CERTAINLY THE VICE PRESIDENT. UNDERSTAND IT AND RICHMOND DOES, AND I THINK IN
PRESIDENT. UNDERSTAND IT AND RICHMOND DOES, AND I THINK IN THE CONVERSATION I HAD WITH
RICHMOND DOES, AND I THINK IN THE CONVERSATION I HAD WITH BIDEN ABOUT THE GEORGE
THE CONVERSATION I HAD WITH BIDEN ABOUT THE GEORGE FLOYD BUILDING, WE HAD A FEW
BIDEN ABOUT THE GEORGE FLOYD BUILDING, WE HAD A FEW MINUTES WHEN HE SPOKE IN
FLOYD BUILDING, WE HAD A FEW MINUTES WHEN HE SPOKE IN TULSA. I THINK HE GETS IT,
MINUTES WHEN HE SPOKE IN TULSA. I THINK HE GETS IT, THE QUESTION IS, CAN THEY GET
TULSA. I THINK HE GETS IT, THE QUESTION IS, CAN THEY GET THE SENATE TO PASS THIS
THE QUESTION IS, CAN THEY GET THE SENATE TO PASS THIS GEORGE
THE SENATE TO PASS THIS GEORGE FLAWED BILL? AND CAN THEY
GEORGE FLAWED BILL? AND CAN THEY BE
FLAWED BILL? AND CAN THEY BE BALANCING. BUT THE WORST THING
BE BALANCING. BUT THE WORST THING IN THE WORLD IS THE ADD MORE
BALANCING. BUT THE WORST THING IN THE WORLD IS THE ADD MORE POLICE WITHOUT HAVING THE
IN THE WORLD IS THE ADD MORE POLICE WITHOUT HAVING THE RESTRAINTS ON POLICE OR THE
POLICE WITHOUT HAVING THE RESTRAINTS ON POLICE OR THE GUIDELINES OR WHAT IS BAD
RESTRAINTS ON POLICE OR THE GUIDELINES OR WHAT IS BAD POLICING. THIS FRIDAY
GUIDELINES OR WHAT IS BAD POLICING. THIS FRIDAY WE ARE GOING TO SENTENCE
POLICING. THIS FRIDAY WE ARE GOING TO SENTENCE THEIR CHILDREN TO JAIL
WE ARE GOING TO SENTENCE THEIR CHILDREN TO JAIL A POLICEMAN WHO KILLED
THEIR CHILDREN TO JAIL A POLICEMAN WHO KILLED GEORGE FLOYD, THIS FRIDAY.
A POLICEMAN WHO KILLED GEORGE FLOYD, THIS FRIDAY. SO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
GEORGE FLOYD, THIS FRIDAY. SO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PRESIDENT, MAKING A SPEECH
SO IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PRESIDENT, MAKING A SPEECH TODAY
PRESIDENT, MAKING A SPEECH TODAY AND A GOOD ONE ABOUT GUN,
TODAY AND A GOOD ONE ABOUT GUN, VIOLENCE, TWO DAYS LATER,
AND A GOOD ONE ABOUT GUN, VIOLENCE, TWO DAYS LATER, WE‘RE PUTTING A POLICEMAN IN
VIOLENCE, TWO DAYS LATER, WE‘RE PUTTING A POLICEMAN IN JAIL
WE‘RE PUTTING A POLICEMAN IN JAIL IN THE SAME WEEK, SO
JAIL IN THE SAME WEEK, SO WE NEED TO
IN THE SAME WEEK, SO WE NEED TO AND THAT WE WALK WITH BOTH
WE NEED TO AND THAT WE WALK WITH BOTH FEET, WE CAN‘T
AND THAT WE WALK WITH BOTH FEET, WE CAN‘T HOP AND THEN EXPECT THAT.
FEET, WE CAN‘T HOP AND THEN EXPECT THAT. WE HAVE HAD A BALANCED WALK
HOP AND THEN EXPECT THAT. WE HAVE HAD A BALANCED WALK UNLESS WE DON‘T HAVE THE OTHER
WE HAVE HAD A BALANCED WALK UNLESS WE DON‘T HAVE THE OTHER UNLIKE THOSE OF US THAT DON‘T
UNLESS WE DON‘T HAVE THE OTHER UNLIKE THOSE OF US THAT DON‘T BUT WE HAVE THE ABILITY
UNLIKE THOSE OF US THAT DON‘T BUT WE HAVE THE ABILITY THEY HAVE BOTH LEGS OF THE
BUT WE HAVE THE ABILITY THEY HAVE BOTH LEGS OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
THEY HAVE BOTH LEGS OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY AND WE OUGHT TO DO THAT AND
WORK SIMULTANEOUSLY AND WE OUGHT TO DO THAT AND WE OUGHT TO INSIST ON THAT
AND WE OUGHT TO DO THAT AND WE OUGHT TO INSIST ON THAT OTHERWISE,
WE OUGHT TO INSIST ON THAT OTHERWISE, WE‘RE GOING TO END UP WITH THE
OTHERWISE, WE‘RE GOING TO END UP WITH THE SAME RESULTS. WE
WE‘RE GOING TO END UP WITH THE SAME RESULTS. WE ENDED UP WITH 30 YEARS AGO
SAME RESULTS. WE ENDED UP WITH 30 YEARS AGO AND IT IS NOT WISE TO MAKE
ENDED UP WITH 30 YEARS AGO AND IT IS NOT WISE TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE AGAIN.
AND IT IS NOT WISE TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE AGAIN. THAT IS RIGHT, THAT IS
THE SAME MISTAKE AGAIN. THAT IS RIGHT, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THAT IS RIGHT, THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. REVEREND AL SHARPTON. THANK
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. REVEREND AL SHARPTON. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE
REVEREND AL SHARPTON. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT. I KNOW YOU‘RE VERY
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT. I KNOW YOU‘RE VERY BUSY PERSON.
TIME OUT. I KNOW YOU‘RE VERY BUSY PERSON. THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME.